foreign
[Applause]
Democrat leaders making excuses after a
violent teen takeover terrorizes Chicago
hundreds rampaging through the streets
blocking traffic smashing car windows
and destroying property two teams were
shot during the chaos and the whole
thing was apparently organized on social
media police were outnumbered and only
managed to make 15 arrests a woman
caught up in the Mayhem describing the
scene after her car was attacked
I jumping in my car my husband go to the
hospital what did they do because the
guys I put in their face
but some top Democrats think it was just
teens being teams Chicago mayor elect
Brandon Johnson condemning what happened
but also said it is quote not
constructive to demonize Youth and the
city's outgoing mayor Lori Lightfoot
said this
there's lots of opportunities for us to
redirect the young people
um to Safe spaces and here's the thing
the vast majority of the young people
who came downtown came downtown because
it was a great weather and an
opportunity to enjoy the city that's
absolutely entirely important there are
a few that came with different
intentions and they have they have and
they will be dealt with but I'm not
going to use your language which I think
is I'm wrong to say that as main
Chicago's cast comes as crime makes more
headlines in New York City Republicans
holding a hearing that featured victims
of liberal policies
all types of criminal elements
free to do what they want when they want
however they want to whomever they want
with no consequences no deterrence
do you believe that the criminals who
murdered your son received Justice
absolutely not there should be no plea
deals for murder do you feel your family
was treated appropriately in the
criminal justice system
absolutely not we were treated like
garbage
Greg we're here again on a Monday a lot
of this crime does seem to happen blow
up and especially in Chicago on the
weekends your take on the Chicago scene
or the New York hearing I just find it
amazing when they when language is
always deemed more offensive than the
Deeds that led to the language
so if you express any outrage about mob
violence and you use terms if if you God
forbid you use the word these people are
acting like animals that's racist how
dare you that is worse than a man
getting beaten up by a by a mob that's
how that's the world we live in right
now I love that the mayor bemoans the
lack of adult supervised activity you
know this is the mayor that canceled
homework
uh the Unspeakable truth here is that
rioting is fun
only because it is unsupervised you
think these miscreants are going to say
you know I wouldn't do this if there
were some activities maybe there might
be a you know a potluck at the church we
could go to the the this there are
mindsets right now that are competing
for the brains and I'm gonna say young
blacks because I'm going to assume that
these crowds were mostly black I can't
tell you know but safe guess just
because we talk about Chicago we talk
about
the crime uh that's going on there
that's affecting black minorities and
black families most Republicans often
say you know you can do anything as long
as you get an education and you stay out
of trouble the world is your oyster and
the left does the opposite they say you
can't do anything uh race racism is an
ever-present overwhelming obstacle and
what does that do ironically is it tells
all these young kids that they can do
anything that they can go out and and
beat the crap out of innocent people and
loot and Destroy property because their
life is already screwed right their life
is already over there's a there's an
unspeakable obstacle in front of them so
it doesn't really matter what they do
so they throw away their lives with
stupid Behavior actually judge that's
interesting that he says that because I
was going to just mention this and of
course you can comment whatever you want
but Robert Peters is the Illinois Senate
Black Caucus chair and he said this
today since I'm a glutton for punishment
and I'm sure I'm going to get the most
unhinged crime weirdo replies but I
would look at the behavior of young
people as a political act and statement
it's a mass protest against poverty and
segregation which then guarantees that
even the 15 people that were arrested
he wouldn't blame them for crimes
committee look there is a real
disconnect between what people are
saying and what is actually happening on
the street they tried to convince us
with this in New York when Kathy hokel
ran for governor she said there's a
perception problem uh and they're trying
to make it a perception problem in
Chicago because the day after this
happened Chicago Police encouraged
people to enjoy what the city has to
offer a day after the team chaos now let
me make one thing perfectly clear you
know you can have uh people come out and
say like Brandon Johnson did the new
mayor of Chicago it is not constructive
to demonize the youth who have otherwise
been starved of opportunity in their own
communities I disagree with them 100
percent it is time to demonize them and
it is time to send them to jail I am
tired of the old argument oh is it the
parents or is it the school or is it the
police who should be in charge right now
when you're in a public area and you
cause this Mayhem and Anarchy this is
when law enforcement's got to come in
and there's got to be consequences and
the way they started this whole Hearing
in New York today Dana was you know uh
Adler Congressman Jerome uh Nadler I
should say comes out and talks about oh
this is really about someone else Dan
Goldman okay this is a guy who ran for
Congress and he was you know I I'm a
former prosecutor and I know how to
prosecute crime and and he then comes
out and he says um your experiences to
The Mother We just heard who painfully
described what happened he said your
experiences are devastating but the
problem is that this is charade this is
a charade that's a cover-up for Donald
Trump this is not about a charade this
is about people living their lives in
front of the rest of us and the sooner
we decide that we there's got to be a
plan to turn this around the sooner
these kids go online and they post we're
going to go out we're going to steal
we're going to beat people up we're
going to jump on cars we're going to
break down buses we're going to have
fights we're going to have those car
spins and by the way in California they
actually passed a law specific to what
they're doing with these what do they
call them Greg with these you these
u-turns when they get the cars and
they're spinning them around yeah
they're spinning I love how you guys
think I would know the answer yeah
I actually don't but there is a new
crime that Outlaws it and it's time to
put these kids in jail
Jessica the you again feel free to talk
about whatever you want but I noticed
this morning each of the Witnesses in
New York that when they gave their
opening statement the very first thing
that they said was I don't care what
your politics are this is what's
happening here in our city yeah I don't
care and so Jose Alba in particular said
I'm not a republican I'm not a Democrat
I'm just here because this is what
happened to me and he's worried that
it's going to happen to other people
most people aren't like the woman
remember who had her baby carriage hit
by the guy who's a liberal and Tucker to
talk to him about she said absolutely
nothing to do with my politics they
tried to kill my kid and me too
and that's how people feel when
something there are certain there are a
few issues that transcend politics crime
happens to be one of them it used to be
I I still think that it does honestly
because the approaches
to how each of the parties are want to
deal with it and how they talk about
people and who they're trying to
demonize are so Stark that you do end up
looking at them differently and to the
point about this being a show trial this
morning I did think I was very happy
that the entire uh cohort of the
Democrats showed up to do this with them
because they have it to others they
happen to others and
they pointed out the fact that
Jim Jordan
represent somewhere where the crime
rates are higher than New York City Uh
Kevin McCarthy Bakersfield you have more
of a chance of being a victim of a
violent crime if you live there than you
do in New York City if they should have
these
meetings in Memphis in St Louis tour the
country go to Toledo go to Alabama what
went on in Alabama this weekend
it's heart-wrenching so there's 16 yeah
just absolutely devastating
um or you have a kid a 16 year old honor
roll kid who shows up to pick up his uh
twin siblings from someone's house
thinks they're there on a play date he
gets shot in the head
this is not about New York City and they
turned it into that because of Alvin
Bragg they wanted to show
fealty to Donald Trump at this moment
where he is saying that that Alvin Bragg
is coming for him because if they cared
about it just being crime they would
show up at a city where the crime is
worse than it is but this is the first
of many hearings they said well all
right well I'm sure they'll be in Jim
Jordan's Hometown and Kevin McCarthy's
Hometown next well this morning on Fox
and Friends Jim Jordan told us they
would be going around the country and
they thought their next stop would be
Chicago I don't think New York is an
inappropriate place to start because
when you talk about the comparison of
the crime going up in the city as
compared to the choice to book and die
and go after a presidential candidate
for what amounts to a bookkeeping we
won't call it an error but a bookkeeping
violation it shows a perverted sense of
priorities in New York here's the thing
you can't stop an act if you can't
describe an act and Greg I I saw the
same thing that you did in that my focus
here is on the choice of words Lori
Lightfoot said I wouldn't choose to call
it mayhem well I'm glad you've taken
that moral stance Lori how about the
mayor election Chicago Brandon Johnson
who also said this judge he said listen
to this tortured and absolutely Sinister
choice of words how about looting
corporations who are taxing the populace
in search so that they can turn a profit
these corporations want to turn a profit
and that amounts to looting this is the
inability to describe an act into your
point judge the point is to change
perception in our minds in the citizens
Minds so that we can no longer
understand reality but when you're in
the middle of what you just saw in
Chicago or you live here in New York
reality is unescapable and the other
thing on the hearing today in New York
is it what is the federal taxpayer Nexus
is that there's a lot of money that goes
to cities in order to Federal money the
Federal Government Federal taxpayers pay
that's you and me so that is the the
Nexus there and the other thing as I
heard today there was this guy in
Chicago saying that it's Walmart's fault
because that's why they have food
deserts because Walmart is trying to
take Advan image of the people and
Walmart just left but they disclosed
four stores and once you do four like
the next four probably is easier after
you make that decision initially hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now